[Musik]
gesundheitschecks schnupfen das ist
natürlich das wetter einmal scheint die
sonne und dann regnet es wieder da weiß
man gar nicht was man anziehen soll
ja das klingt gar nicht was über wochen
ja also ich wäre da ja auch schaaf wohl
unter sich
die görtz doch mit der teufel normale
schafwolle natürlich schon aber ich
nehme ja da merinowolle merinowolle ist
schafwolle in einer neuen dimension
die kann 30 prozent ihrer ihres eigenen
gewichts er kann die an feuchtigkeit
aufnehmen ohne dass sie nass anfühlt und
das kratzt dann wirklich nicht überhaupt
nicht das wäre mein beruf er auch viel
zu gefährlich stellt sich vor ich will
ihm ob korrekt enthaupten und dann habe
ich immer das maßen spitze
ich könnte brauchen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und schön ruhig halten
der nächste bitte servus ich könnte mir
meine videos an ganzen talkshow von der
früh bis auf macht und wenn es ja so
geht dann muss es halt
sie müssen bloß auf der mediathek
klicken und dann rutscht kinder schauen
was wohin früh spaß